fairytail has fired up our hearts are
made our tears shed for over 10 years
now and through the years we've seen
plenty of heartbreak and sentimental
scenes emerge from the much-loved manga
and anime we've cheered the beloved
mages on a cried for them when they were
at their lowest points and laughed
alongside them throughout their
adventures with the show currently on
its final season we're counting down the
10 most heartbreaking scenes from fairy
tale from emotional character deaths to
tearful goodbyes let's take a look at
the scenes that made many of us become a
faithful member of the fairy tale family
[Music]
[Music]
we start off the list with the moment
when Alexis leaves fairytale the
decision to wage a war against members
of his own guild ultimately led to him
being kicked out while the action itself
wasn't what moved us what came next
surely did as the Fantasia parade
carried on and everyone in Magnolia
enjoyed themselves a familiar symbol
coined by Laxus at a young age with his
grandfather near him rose into the hands
of all the fairy tale members a symbol
known as I'm looking your way in moving
Laxus enough to break down and look
towards his family with tears in his
eyes knowing his family was still there
waiting for him to return a better and
changed man was more than enough for the
electric maid to carry on and move on
from his past mistakes
[Music]
[Music]
oh my no no no no Katara Cory Marathi
diversity night
at number 9 we have Dalal's arrest where
arthur Christ Virgil Oh which allow back
on the good side once more many members
of the Fairy Tail guild look forward to
what happens next for the once enemy
wizard
however criminal pasts aren't easy to
overlook especially in the eyes of the
law
soon enough Jenelle's taken away to
serve his time for his crimes against
Fiore despite the efforts of his new
friends and allies his parting words
were a memory of how he came to give
Arthur her last name before disappearing
as dawn comes the next morning we're
greeted by the appearance of fairy tales
strongest femur having a total breakdown
a scene that left us in awe of how even
the strongest of us have our breaking
points it's Kristi soda Bushido birthday
money
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
static next up it's the moment when
Wendy finds out the truth about Cait
shelter if you thought jellal's exit was
hard then what came after would prove to
be even worse Cait shelter the girl that
took Wendy in and raised her would soon
be revealed to be nothing more than a
mere illusion created by the guild
master in order to make her feel happy
and loved and while Wendy's time with
her guild would soon come to an end
seeing hair tears for her guild master
and its member to return stuck to our
hearts what really did it and made this
moment was when Wendy was at her lowest
oza reached out to help her knowing the
pain of losing someone you care for OSHA
opened a new door for Wendy and helped
to find a new family that family being
the Fairy Tail guild you do Anika
[Music]
very
at number 7 its Makarov sacrifice we've
seen plenty of sacrifices and tough
decisions made in the most recent season
but few seem to compare with macros
decision to lessen the number of
enchanted foot soldiers so his children
could continue the battle without having
to deal with the minor threats this
comes at a cost however and by using
fairy law it ultimately leads the Fairy
Tail guild master to his own death even
though he managed to defeat 70 to 80% of
the enemy standing sterically in place
and with a protective stance Makarov
passes away and leaves his children
knowing the true cost of war and that
they now have something to fight for as
well as the desire not to lose anyone
else in the final battle between
themselves and Zarin
[Music]
[Music]
moving on to number six we have all
tears sacrifice the grand magic games
and in a way none of us thought possible
with an eerie warning of the future and
many of us witnessing the death of many
of our favorite characters it was hard
to accept the best possible ending all
tear a villain who'd been moved to do
good deciding her own life was not worth
more than those around her castes last
ages in the hope of saving her allies
from an unspeakable fate after she cast
her spell and only manages to rewind
time by a mere minute her thoughts about
her life being worth only a minute takes
us on an emotional roller coaster
however what comes next is what truly
made all two years sacrifice stick in
our hearts as grey catches sight of her
old and gray form on the way back to
Magnolia she tells him not to seek her
out with the idea of him losing his
mother and daughter who helped save him
he's moved to tears himself as were we
[Music]
next we have guard eels death Guardian
red fox was introduced originally as a
foil for Natsu a dragon slayer with
different morals and at times
questionable actions but when he joined
a Fairy Tail and changed for the better
it was clear many of us were becoming
attached to him from how he defended the
lovable bookworm levy to giving his all
to make Panther Lily his accede
companion gajeel quickly became a
favorite in the series but when blood
man's vortex proved too much for him to
handle he ultimately decided he needed
to take the enemy out with him as well
if need be
despite levies plead for him to let her
help she's held back by Panther Lily
then comes guard gos confession saying
he wanted to be with her forever and
that a future without her was his
greatest fear then he's gone and many of
us were left terrified that we just
witnessed the end of the Dragon Slayer
but luckily by Irene's magic he was
alive and well again despite the loop of
emotions many had been thrown through
[Music]
[Music]
at number 4 we have Beauty Lucy's death
the arrival of The Melancholy Lucy
Heartfilia from the Future made viewers
know that what was to come next would be
unexpected with future road dead set on
killing the current day Lucy it was
clear the future Lucy knew she'd have to
sacrifice herself in order to save the
future and her own past self she asked
to see her guild mark once more as her
final words as she takes her last breath
we see how greatly her death would
affect the most influential people in
her life from Wendy and Carlos stunned
silence with their eyes brimming with
tears
the Happy's tearful goodbye tribute to
Lucy and then finally the Natsu's anger
desire to make sure this doesn't happen
again to Lucy
it drove many of us to tears so much
that when future Lucy did indeed pass on
and meet her guild once more in the
afterlife we cried in relief along with
the celestial mage
[Music]
next up its Silver's goodbye Gray's past
and the trauma of Delhi aura drove him
to become a stronger and capable wizard
so when the titer rose gilda raised his
father from the dead
it seemed that gray was going to relive
the past of losing his father to make
matters worse Juvia was forced to choose
between giving her own life so gray
could remain with his father or kill the
necromancer who brought him back in
order to defeat the demon guilt in the
end with a teary goodbye and a new
ability gray says goodbye to his father
Silver's parting words help both Juvia
and gray move forward but not without
feeling guilty for their actions college
Cara Worricker
[Music]
at number two we have another DEATH yes
you guessed it it's igneous death the
tartar ozark not only had the parting of
Gray's father but also of Natsu's
adopted father
igneel as well since the beginning of
the series Natsu had been searching for
his father who disappeared when the pair
were reunited it seemed all as well or
at least until acknowledged iya ended
igneous life right there before Natsu's
eyes
even after Mart gear was defeated and
the other Dragon Slayers were bidding
goodbye to their own dragon parents
Natsu was mourning the death of his own
dragon parent but despite the pain and
tears the igneous death brought not to
move even further and vowed to get even
stronger to protect the ones he loved
from the same faith
[Music]
[Music]
and finally at number one we have the
moment when Lucy breaks Aquarius is key
Lucy Heartfilia wasn't known as a brutal
fighter in the fairy tale series however
went back against the wall and with her
guild members in need of her help she's
always willing to give her all in order
to save them thus she was given the
ultimate choice to make
save her friends or keep one of the few
Momentum's of her mother
the celestial spirit Aquarius despite
the hard decision and Aquarius pushing
her to do it Lucy was still conflicted
to the point where her own life was in
danger thanks to jackal but with
Aquarius is moving words Lucy breaks a
key and summons the celestial spirit
king despite her saving the day it was
clear the loss of Aquarius was something
that would take her a while to get over
and even in the present-day anime Lucy's
resolved to find aquarius's new key
shows how dedicated she is to having the
spirit at her side once more
my mother Sarang it's sad to think
fairytale will end soon but looking back
at all the memories in good times
they've shared and given us it's clear
that the anime had become so much more
than a mere show too many of us from the
guild members hardships to their tears
and resolve to move forward we've been
there alongside them each step of the
way and while the final arc soon to come
to a close no matter how much time
passes or news shows we fall in love
with fairy tale will always remain
strong in our hearts we'll always
remember to look their way when we need
a reminder of true friendship family and
magic
so which moments did you feel we're the
saddest make sure you comment below like
the video if you did and subscribe to
the channel for more anime content I'll
see you next time on Vinnie Chu
[Music]